but I'm saying even meat not too much
eating meat no good once a week maybe
maximum and then vegetable who moves all
good Arabic fruit Middle East like in
the old time like in the Muslim look at
the Muslim bread almond Apple go read
read you discover in a Muslim a lots of
good thing a very smart Prophet Mohammed
he knew what's good for the future about
the body so look at that don't ask me
and believe me you have everything Salam
alaikum greetings of peace welcome to
the Deen show did you know that one of
the founding fathers if not many of them
one that we know for sure had his own
copy of the verbatim word of god
almighty the Quran some would even say
that the Constitution that we have today
was influenced by Islam well that's what
we're gonna be talking about much much
more here with my guests Sheikh face oh
hi mother how are you how are you let's
see you nice to see you how you been so
your engineer by profession yes and also
you've been in the field of educating
humanity Americans in particular here
and many of clearing many of the
misconceptions about Islam and
delivering the true message of Islam yes
sir
yeah how long you've been doing that I
think it's over 40 years 40 years you
got a lot of experience huh yeah yeah
now before we get into the main thing
that we wanted to talk about that's kind
of goes over what's actually written in
his book and you also have a another
book here these are a couple historians
that are gonna be we're gonna be picking
through some of the things that they're
saying and these are these are not
Muslim authors are they no no we're
dealing with for crisis here they say a
pandemic the corona virus what do you
what are your thoughts on what's going
on well the best statement was made in
France about the women the Muslim women
who are doing the club the club means
covering their face with the exception
of their eyes
and wearing gloves and don't kiss and
don't hug they said they are absolutely
Corona disease preventer who said the
enemy in France in France in France now
now where people were really criticizing
Muslim women for wearing hijab and
covering their face or covering their
body totally now they see the benefit of
being core this way and they are Corona
free free hopefully this is a great
prevention from yeah so they're saying
this these are the French newspaper yeah
that was in a French newspaper and as a
matter of fact you'll find if you google
on Muslim women and Corona you're gonna
find that the how they show somebody
with a mouse mask and gloves and
what-have-you and how a Muslim woman is
already self protected even they went
further than that they said that Reza
strip yes because of the siege that the
whole world is putting on them yes it's
a corona rip free oh that ok this area
because he can't go out and nobody can
come in yeah and he can buy anything
from anywhere except locally so it is
but here people do not realize that God
has many soldiers work of RAM to
establish justice on this planet Earth
it could be a bird and we have seen that
many over 1,400 years when the African
tried to destroy the building in Kaaba
and God Almighty will send birds with
little stones in their mouths and their
peak and destroy the army and they went
with their elephant back couldn't
destroy Kaabah and we will find out
throughout history that God uses whens
tsunamis and use different natural
things
to make people wake up to his existence
and to stop injustice to each other
everybody talks about justice but when
they get him power they forget about
justice and this Corona is waking up the
whole world its ass wake up as a matter
of fact China before the corona epidemic
came about they were saying we are a
power that nobody can destroy it and you
remember a statement like that was made
on the Titanic they said this is a ship
that God cannot destroy and it was
destroyed and on its first trip the
Titanic the Titanic yeah
and they chose that statement again they
said that Chinese no the one with the
Titanic that I said legend said this is
a ship that God cannot destroy yeah I
can cannot sink cannot sink and it it
was sank on the first trip uh-huh and
the Chinese just recently before the
epidemic they were saying we are at a
point so strong that nobody can push us
back and God is telling everybody be
just to everybody so that can be just to
us mm-hmm so what happened in China with
millions of Muslims being prosecuted it
was the answer now we can see that
happening in India the burning Muslims
are life in the streets of India and the
whole world is just watching and doing
nothing is it amazing that just
everybody's just quiet they're asleep
and this is a modern day like genocide
is happening and if a Muslim if a Muslim
have burned a roach and any street
you're gonna see the whole media talking
about the Muslim terrorists and anti
humanity and anti animals yeah you have
with the Chinese you have a modern-day
Inquisition then you have these bandits
criminals terrorizing innocent human
beings in India and energy oh gosh we
are yeah and Kashmir is the locked up
they're still locked down in Kashmir
well long have been locked down like
animals yeah you know of animals were
locked down people would have more of an
uproar that's true yeah so this is
what's happening God Almighty
giving a message to the world bees us to
each other be just to each other because
you're gonna be on this planet Earth and
you're gonna share it together mm-hmm
isn't that amazing that you can see like
you were saying that you just don't know
what means that the Almighty God
Almighty Allah can use to wake people up
to bring them back this can be a
punishment also a mercy for some of they
turn back towards the Almighty towards
God Almighty Allah but you need to to
see this whatever it is this
Korona it needs to be magnified I
believe by like a hundred thousand or
something like that
and that's exactly what the president of
China he went to many mosques in China
yes
apologizing and asking them to pray did
he yes yeah this is this in the media
public media yeah ask them to pray for
God to save China the Chinese president
yes Wow so now what happened is he but
is there any changes being made it's
kind of reminds me of faroan Pharaoh a
God have given us many examples in the
Quran when people are stuck and they
can't get anywhere then they realize
that there is a God and the as God Oh
God Almighty if you just get us out of
our troubles would be the most obedient
and God will say he would get them out
of their troubles knowing that they're
gonna negate on their promise yeah but
hopefully the Chinese this time they
would wake up because not thousands of
Chinese are becoming Muslims but it says
in some publications millions of Chinese
are becoming Muslims now why because
they see the way Muslim live and the way
Muslim eat is completely different than
them and Muslims have not been infected
by Corona as much as the non-muslims
have been done now they are thinking
about the way they eat animals and their
way of life sex and what have you and
the way Muslims eat
good food and not only that they wash up
five times a day for prayers and they go
to God seeking his help now they see the
difference in the two ways of life as a
matter of fact the whole world now is
seeing most of the precautions against
Crona it says make sure that you wash
your nose and make sure that water go
through your nose and make sure that
water go through your mouth and this is
what Muslims do five times a day five
times a day before prayer you have Salah
for prayer and this has been just
self-protection coming from God so it's
time for the whole world to know that
there is something good in Islam and
Islam was sent as the last message to
save humanity from themselves from
themselves everybody think we can't do
anything as I mentioned before this is a
ship that God cannot sink
God sent it to tell them that you can do
better
yeah inshallah God wanted people take
these these reminders these wake-up
calls and turn back and a lot of times
when when it's wonderful what you're
saying because when people really come
at Islam with an open heart and open
mind they look at it and they see a lot
of these blessings a lot of these
wisdoms that are there for the benefit
of society humanity as an individual and
as a whole now you you are actually
sharing an interesting story they when
you when you have to take your
citizenship you have to or what was it
you were studying the concept to you had
to study the Constitution for yes yeah
and the Bill of Rights okay and when I
when I did I found out this sounds like
Islamic stuff as a matter of fact if you
go to Harvard University you're gonna
have you're gonna have a plaque there
saying that Muhammad peace be upon him
is the most just man in the history of
mankind where is this this is in the
Harvard University University yeah and
not only that one of the greatest law
makers right lawmakers yeah yeah and
they also caught one verse from Surat
Annisa
about justice
I think it's verse 193 from so that's
the one that said Harvard University
have that there is two two statements at
the law school of Yale they have this
verse say this is the most just
statement ever made I mean if you think
that's deep that's really profound yes
and in Harvard University they saying
that Muhammad is the greatest man ever
lived
Sal Allah says noise which means as a
matter of fact you know the the movie
star with a French name that used to do
double-oh-seven movies are the James
Bond yeah James Bond movies he has a
French name yeah they had quite a few of
them they were one with a French name he
says great you discover a Muslim a lots
of good thing the best food and the best
remedies is to follow the life of
Prophet Mohammad saw oh yeah that's over
them yeah when then Van Damme yeah yeah
when they're but I'm saying even meat
not too much eating meat no good once a
week maybe maximum and then vegetable
who moves all good Arabic food Middle
East like in the hotel like in the
Muslim look at the Muslim bread almond
Apple go read read you discover in a
Muslim a lots of good thing a very smart
Prophet Mohammed he knew what's good for
the future about the body so look at
that
don't ask me and believe me you have
everything he was saying yeah he was
talking about Prophet Mohammed van Dam
was talking about
yeah Muhammad he knows he know it from
from he'll his study and yeah the
martial arts and the food and everything
and he did a little bit studying and he
said follow Muhammad something like that
yes yeah
and not only that there is there is a
scientist who found that Muslim women
are the cleanest woman in the world how
he did he found out through his research
that when a man have a relation with a
moment he leaves his imprint and that
imprint
there for three months to four months
and ten days and this is what the Quran
says that a woman wouldn't marry if she
is divorced for three months why because
if the imprint of two men will mix in
her body it will cause her problems and
diseases and for a woman that her
husband passed away there is four months
and ten days and because of that he
became a Muslim this was the scientist a
scientist yeah unfortunately I don't
hold names good except but maybe next
time though these are those are from the
small it reminds me of you know the man
who came up to one of the companions of
Prophet Muhammad peace and wasn't be
upon him and he said your prophet which
is actually a prophet for the whole of
mankind living today and yesterday
Prophet Muhammad the seal of the
prophets just like Moses Abraham Jesus
came to the same message worship the
Creator not the creation he just happens
to be the last and final messenger so at
that time they asked him he said o your
prophet taught you everything even how
to go to the bathroom right so from the
smallest things we're just talking about
the small details but when you study the
details now these some of these wisdoms
are mentioned imagine the great things
like nobody attacks Islam on the
theology the theology of the pure
monotheism just worshipping one and one
God alone but going back to some of
these smaller details like just going to
the bathroom
they've did you know just the the the
proper way to to wash yourself there was
when I was in Bosnia there was a Serbian
doctor who was talking about because
there is rectal cancer and other harms
that because people not washing
themselves properly down yes there right
after you they use the bathroom number
two specifically in this case but we've
been talking how to do that right you
won't believe there is a life professor
in Minneapolis area Minnesota he went to
Malaysia as a missionary
first he lived with a Muslim family and
he according to him and I met him
several times he will go to the bathroom
and he will find a pot with water and he
didn't know what did that for but he
really never get a chance to ask the
Muslim family about it why they have the
pot in the bathroom with the water yeah
yeah and then he moved from their place
and lived with a Buddhist and he found
that they don't have that part in their
bathroom yeah so he asked him how come
you don't have a pot so they start
making fun of the Muslims and ridiculing
the put slips because they wash
themselves with the water so now he he
look at it and he said Islam goes to
that much of details even how to go to
the bathroom and to clean yourself yeah
now he's masha'Allah a Muslim mission or
he accepted Islam yes and then also the
they did some tests were they with the
UV lighting they were testing people I
heard this that will do no this is
specifically for people when you go to
the urinals and you stand up in orient
oh yeah
and now you can only see with this
special UV lighting but what they saw
was because of the backsplash from the
urine people were pretty much walking
with urine all over themselves but we
have obviously in Islam we have the when
you go to the magic number two but also
when you go to urinate Muslims this fall
in the Sunnah of the last profunda
message sent the mankind of Prophet
Muhammad you would sit so this avoids
you walking around with urine on
yourself and dung between years not only
that recently yeah another professor he
was checking the image of human beings
and it most of the one that he have
checked it seems that the unsettling and
peaceful and then one time he did the
same imaging of a Muslim and he found
that he isn't quite tranquility and
peace with himself and he found out the
reason was for doing although washing
yourself and when he did will do to
non-muslims
their image changed and they have peace
and tranquility this is the evolution of
ablution for praying yeah yes yes so
allah subhanaw taala me the statement
this quran will always lead to the best
this means regardless what time and what
era you are what knowledge you have
there is going to be something even
better that this Quran will tell you as
time goes on as a matter of fact there
is a professor and I think she is in
Germany she is a sort of orientalist and
she said whoever says the Quran is not
fit for all times they neither had to be
exempt and God is showing the world
today how if you follow the hygienic
procedures of the Muslims you can save
yourself from a deadly disease which is
simply if you go anywhere they say wash
your hands with water and soap inhale
water drink water make sure that your
mouth is moist and if you touch anything
make sure that you clean yourself yeah
so we're just talking about the purity
because that's that's a part of faith
demand it's purity of cleanliness and
how and we're just giving some examples
that's just amazing just from those
examples there there's so much good
because I mean we see what happens when
people were in the Dark Ages at one
point right then they were not taking
baths for four months just putting
perfume or cologne over and you had
sickness and disease and whatnot but at
that time you had Muslims who are
following the example of Prophet
Muhammad peace and buzzer top and all
the prophets and messengers and they
were implementing this because this
comes from the divine yes yeah he knows
better than anybody else exactly and
this is for everybody this is not
exclusive just for us this is for the
person watching this is for everybody
this way of life is for everybody
absolutely so what happened out so
you're you're reading this the
Constitution and what's this historian
is it that talks about some of this
stuff and what
you what came to your mind that they how
much influence did they have and did
they know about Islam Thomas Jefferson
had his own copy of the Quran not only
he had his own copy of the Quran he
ordered somebody to give him even a
better translation of the Quran and not
only him but several of the founder
that's why the subtitle it says is lemon
the founders was around Islam and the
founders of America of America yeah
they studied Islam and they studied the
Quran they talk and not only about
Muslims at that time they're talking
about the future could be a Muslim
president as you mentioned yes at that
time they have slaves but nevertheless
when they studied Quran they came up
with the idea of freedom of religion and
freedom of speech and freedom of
defending yourself and those are things
taken out of the Quran the straight from
the Quran now everybody talks about
Sharia as a bad word but really Sharia
would the constitution of America
because most of the Muslim countries
they don't even follow yeah that that's
ironic because I mean you have any any
any person who loves Moses nobody is
going to get bent out of shape who was
God conscious and says I thought you
can't if you're Christian you love Moses
if you're a Jew you love Moses and
nobody's gonna like throw out the Ten
Commandments that's Sharia actually yes
right as a matter of fact part of our
Islam and you find it at the end couple
verses of the ShoreTel butter at the cow
it says that the Prophet and the
believers they believed in God and the
angels and the scriptures and all the
prophets without distinction and this is
part of Muslims belief is who believe in
all the prophets and the messenger of
god with no separation and
no distinctions between them that's
beautiful that's one of the things that
many people they find captivating is
when it just makes sense that
chronological order from the beginning
one God one message one way of life not
all these different religions and now
they're contradictory could they
contradict each other contradictory
messages it's just the same message
worship one and only one God the Creator
don't worship the creation be morally
upright do good deeds and if you fall
short like we will we're human beings
turn back to the all loving forgiving
God repent directly to him no one's
dying for your sins and that's how you
get salvation right by His grace by His
mercy living a good morally upright life
following the messenger that was sent to
you and Mohammed just happens to be that
if you were during living during like we
know Jesus's time you would have to
follow his teachings today or Moses
teaches at his time but Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him now this is
the messenger for president Trump for
all the Christians where everybody he's
a massive messenger for everybody as a
matter of fact recently there is a rabbi
chief rabbi in Israel who have studied
Islam yes and now we went back to the
original scripts of the Torah yes and he
found out that indeed Mohammed is the
last and the seal of the prophets and
he's the one is gonna come at the end as
a matter of fact there is if you googled
somewhere on the internet you find out
many of the Jews when you go to the
Wailing Wall they say more men Mohammed
Mohammed Hamid why why would these be
saying that because it is in their
script and do you know it without
knowing what he's talking about but he
became a Muslim and he exposed the
corruption that happened to the Torah
yeah in the past which one you can they
can look this up people can look this up
it just came to me looking at the
internet yeah it's a YouTube just going
to YouTube and look for a rabbi exposing
their and confirming Mohammed is the
last prophet it reminds me you have
learned Christians
no fool during the time of Prophet
Muhammad you had a he he was one who
knew the scriptures is that time and
when it was declared that Prophet
Muhammad brought this news that he was
indeed a messenger people knew him as
having the most he was the most honest
the most trustworthy and when he came
with it this was a Christian who
followed him yes and you had the new
Jesse also the nagesh yeah yeah he was
the King he also at the end accepted
Islam so these are Christians accepting
Islam then you had scholars of Judaism
at that time also what was it Salah ebin
Salaam Salaam he also he was someone who
accepted and others what was the you had
that situation where the the the man he
was Jewish he lent some money to the the
Muslims and then he reneged after three
months he said I'm gonna come back he
came back there after a month he started
to because it was one thing he was
testing he wanted to tell all the
ceilings fit was just yeah his forebears
yes all the signs fit that he was indeed
the messenger that the the Jews came to
yesterday to Medina waiting for the
final messenger to come and then he saw
the signs but he wanted to test them in
his forbearance and then he started to
you know slander to you know attack
assalam was always cool he was just nice
and never raised his voice at all yeah
and then what he accepted is Ana no
matter the aunt asked him he he the
Prophet SAW said give him his money and
more because you scared him ah ah ah ah
yes yeah you know this this generation
yeah and then he ended up asking him why
did you do that he said because I saw
the signs he fit them I did with just
one sign left and that was the quality
of forbearance yes if he has the power
meaning that if he can punish that and
he's inability to do so that he would
but he didn't he showed mercy leniency
you see any you see the people do not
realize that God have created us in the
most wonderful way that we can use our
brain to think and if we think properly
we're going to be led to the truth
properly and anyone who
really honest to themselves and want to
find out the truth they will find the
truth and the truth will be that
Muhammad peace be upon him was the last
and the seal of the prophets and Islam
is the way of life and God have made it
responsibility in him to protect that
Quran from being altered or corrupted
and the fact is there is millions if not
hundreds of millions of Muslims who
memorized the Quran from one from the
beginning to the end not only memorize
it as words but they memorize it the way
that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
utter it 1400 years ago yeah that by
itself convinced all the world that
there is only one Quran and it's not
only one Quran written Quran it is
pronounced the same way as it has been
pronounced by Prophet Muhammad SAW Salim
and the companions at that time 1400
years ago so really and truly if you
want the best look in Islam so now let's
go back to this this is very profound
very interesting that many people don't
know that because it's kind of like
people who are really narrow-minded some
people they and some people have some
just some racist qualities you know they
think that okay America this is how it
is it's for us our type are our color
our look you know and Muslims are the
other anyone who doesn't you know talk
like Louis walk like us have slang like
laws whatever it is case they're not one
of us and Muslims when they'll often get
attacked you know these people will come
many of these these haters whatever you
want to call them to say go back home
right they'll have you have you
witnessed some of these things oh yeah
but now when you come and you talk about
the influence that Islam had on the
founding fathers and then they not you
in particular but the historians to talk
about let's talk about that that you
found that Muslims who came here you
know who are some of the originals here
in the Americas yes the
Muslims once they came to Spain which is
like the second century of Asia which is
like 1777 hundred after Christ they look
at the ocean and he said there must be
something behind that so they are the
one who really discovered America and
Muslim kings who lived in North Africa
and West Africa they send missions over
missions over missions to go to the land
in South America and North America and
they lived with the Native Americans and
the Native Americans accepted Islam and
there are many historian who says that
majority of the Native Americans were
Muslims they have one of the best
culture and the best society and the
best government system however as many
historian you will read that they say
history is written by the powerful they
have demonized the Native Americans they
killed the Native Americans and it is
acknowledged that most of the African
slaves that he brought to America we're
actually Muslims and they force him to
convert to Christianity and now I think
his name is Ali he's just he have his
memoir in Arabic and he wrote about his
history in in slavery and many of the
founders they had slaves but later on as
we see for example Lincoln he was
fighting for the slaves where did he get
this idea what did he get this idea
Islam talks about freeing the next of
the slaves yeah so it's it's you it's a
mind-boggling information that people
are not aware of it and there are
intention from certain group of people
to make sure that this information never
comes to the public and I think most
people they don't
like being lied to so you have a lot of
deceit and a lot of deception in the
history you you have a lot of the seat
and the information that's come come out
there people you're writing books like
the third jihad and other books that are
out there and and and these these people
become victim to a lot of this false
negative propaganda deliberate you know
distortion I you look at some of these
things you're like man this stuff is way
out there it's like they couldn't twist
information and give half-truths and
which is actually just lies then and
this is what much of the information
that people are getting to them and then
making making the wrong decisions and
having the wrong picture about Islam but
I think if we just go and because we've
used this word Muslim I have you found
that a lot of times if you can just sit
with someone and you can explain to them
what it means the word itself that most
people say even before I've done this
and I've explained to people before
saying the word Muslim and the majority
of people almost everyone would say yeah
I'm that they would agree with that I
would define the word give the
definition and I would say how you feel
about that being being a person who has
who is grateful who submits his or her
will to the crater the heavens the earth
the one and only one God this is just
one example and people say yeah that's I
mean that's that's a Muslim and that's
why in the Quran it says that all
prophets and messengers were Muslims why
because they submitted themselves to the
will of God Jesus did it
Muslim Abraham Abraham as a matter of
fact there is a verse in the Quran says
Abraham was not a Christian or a Jew but
he was a Muslim one who submitted his
will to a God Almighty to Allah yes yeah
and if we think about God Almighty and
the bounties that we live in it
shouldn't we really submit to his will
and see what he wants us to do so we can
do it right and again he tells us
throughout history I'm not asking for
myself I'm asking for you I want you to
live on this planet Earth in peace and
harmony so when the end of the world
happens then he's gonna come on
in heaven yeah so these are when when
some of the basic principles that we
found that the Constitution was written
upon because the Sharia this is like the
word that's used and it's like creates
fear in the hearts but yeah like I said
earlier Jesus brought Jesus taught
Sharia that's God's almighty zloz
legislations the you see that these
these people
the Talmud Thomas Jefferson says and the
founding fathers when they the original
writers of the Constitution you have
this in Islam the the guarantee of
freedom freedom and protection of the
individual and the community and the
property and the walking and the owning
and defending himself all that stuff is
like you don't have to right now where
you have to fight for that right that's
given to you like if you are in a Muslim
majority country let's say in India
right now they're taking away their
citizenship they're killing numbers you
if you have a right now to practice your
religion to be a Christian to be a Jew
to practice within a Muslim majority
country you don't have to fight that's
not that's not gonna be taken away from
you this is your God we're right people
forget the Sharia gives you this right
forget the history of India it was once
rule by Muslims and Hindus flourished
there and their rights were protected
yeah and their temples were protected
and nobody forced them to change the
religion or to do anything and they were
and that's how they became majority and
he ruled the country
why because was it because Muslims that
were against them or Muslim gave them
the freedom to do what do you want as
far as they don't hurt anybody else you
have these laws these laws that are just
overnight passed and then you lose all
your rights but Islam gives you that is
you don't have to worry about that being
changed yes because human beings they
change why because human beings are the
same it's just God as a matter of fact
there is a verse in the Quran says it is
his miracle that he created you with
different colors and
from tongues but we are the same human
beings descendant of Adam and Eve we are
the same family of humanity we have the
same needs we all have two arms and five
fingers in every hand we all have earth
to eat an urge to do other things we all
have the feeling that I like to be free
and I like to be protected and I don't
like a government to be nosy in my
affairs as a matter of fact there was an
example that people came to Alma Reville
hot tub and they told him one of our
neighbors is an alcoholic yeah yeah and
he asked him so what do you want me to
do he said we wanted to punish him he
said how did you find out he said we
looked through the door spun up holes
they were spying he said I swear to God
if he have poked your eyes out of your
face I wouldn't have punished him
because you were trespassing his
property so whatever you do behind your
door they give you even freedom if even
you do bad things and as far as justice
unless he the person or she admitted
that he did something wrong or it has
been openly known in the community that
they did something wrong then the law
cannot punish you for a crime can you
imagine for a crime if you look at Islam
and their case of adultery a man cannot
accuse his wife of adultery unless he
gets four witnesses that they have seen
his wife committing adultery how could
any human being get four witnesses to
look at his wife while she is committing
adultery as an option after that if you
can get four witnesses you will swear
four times that I'm telling the truth
and the fifth time you swear that if he
was a lying may God curse
come on him and the same thing applies
to the woman she will make for authors
that she is right and he is wrong
and the fifth one that gets curse will
be on her if she was lying this is in
just one crime which is one of the major
crimes that really everywhere in the
world
is breaking homes and societies so this
is how Islam looks at it justice justice
justice well yeah we often hear that no
justice no peace but so Islam is really
about justice justice establishing
everybody wants justice what what wasn't
it the when when the Americas when when
established itself that it was the
Muslims and in particular I think it was
was it Morocco that they were in support
and great allies of the Americas oh yeah
yeah because the other they were the
dominant force in that time of the world
they were dominating the ocean and they
were helping the United States the most
taxing the Muslim the Muslims were
protecting protecting the US yeah trades
in the sea and the United States were
paying them what about you here a lot a
lot of these these anti Islam fobs and
other Islam haters that they they'll say
that no these Muslims were terrorizing
the flea they're the Pirates they were
the Pirates as I said before it's
powerful right history for example I
just ran into something that most
Americans do not know and it is called
the blackmailing of President Woodrow
Wilson and it's written by a Jewish
Zionist who broke off the Zionist
movement and you can google it
blackmailing of whether President
Woodrow Wilson one of the lawyers Jewish
lawyers from New York when we drew
Wilson was elected the first time in
1912 he came to the White House
and the president thought he is coming
to congratulate him said unfortunately
mr. president I'm coming with bad news
and he laid bunch of letters on the
table and those letter were love letters
that the widow Wilson wrote to his
colleague professor's wife while he was
teaching yeah and he said the woman is
asking for $50,000 he said I don't have
that money he said don't worry we'll pay
it for you but the first appointment to
the Supreme Court will tell you who to
appoint and that was the judge who
justified for the United States of
America to get involved in world war and
they get involved in 1917 and 1918 why
because the British told them if you can
get the Americans to help us with the
war we're gonna give you Palestine
nobody writes about it
why because those who controlling the
media don't want you or me or the
average American to know about this
history where America have lost billions
of dollars and lost hundreds of
thousands of lives for no reason
whatsoever
the US has nothing to do with the World
War one or World War two but
nevertheless they paid dearly dearly in
both wars why to establish Israel so
nobody talks about this as a matter of
fact there is a British lady one of the
with the title lady in British she is
going around now saying there is a state
for the Jews which is called the
Republic the Jewish Republic in Russia
standing when he came he was trying to
have every ethnicity lived together so
there was a Jewish group living in South
East Russia and he call it the Jewish
Republic and Jews from Europe or going
there to live but nevertheless Weisman
and the
owners of Israel they wanted to go to
Palestine for no reason whatsoever as
manufacture she's going around saying
the solution for the Palestinian and the
Middle East problem is for the Jews to
go to the Jewish Republic and China and
Russia and for the Palestinians to keep
their land but nobody talks about it and
you have to dig to find it only few
people and most of them they pay their
life for speaking the truth
mm-hmm unfortunately Wow yeah you are
you don't you have to dig a little bit
but this is a this is directly it's
unfortunate also that when news comes to
us we have this also solution in the
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah the
Quran where Allah says if some news
comes to you verify it check you know
this is what we need to do yeah but you
you it seems like a lot of times you got
to dig a little bit because the truth
doesn't get the headlines the the actual
truth is not mainstream no people
control as a matter of fact the last
statement I made I heard about the last
the the current election one of the
professors and one of the universities
he was saying we don't really have a
two-party system we have one party with
two wings because what you see that
Democratic Party is doing now they are
shooting themselves in the foot - for
who for unfortunately the paving the way
for trumpet would the way they huddling
themselves and not supporting the one
who is more competent and more honest
and this is what the US Constitution
which is taken from Islam if you look at
the story of Moses peace be upon him
when he left
Egypt he went to Midian and he found out
that there is people watering their
animals with the exception of two women
they cannot come close to the water and
he held them to water their animals and
later on one of the women came to him
and said my father when I pay you off
for what she did yeah and when he went
to tribe prophet tribe
and he told him his story guess what his
daughter said father please hire him the
best you can hire is the competent and
the honest company an honest there isn't
this is what it the United States
Constitution it says this is the
delegates that they're going to be in
Congress or Senate they should be
competent and honest but do we really do
that the system which according to Islam
which they have it is people will
nominate you not you go and ask people
to nominate you you see the difference
here
Islam is people will nominate the
candidate why because they see their
activity and her service we see the
trustworthiness and that reference yeah
not only on the country level but on the
community level believe it or not the
only time it happened in the last maybe
century has happened in Tunisia the
president of Tunisia he was a professor
in school and his student where the one
who nominated him and the one who ran
his campaign why because he felt is
confident is competent and honest yeah
and this is exactly what Quran and what
Islam tells us how to select our leaders
and not only that Raza sorry we said the
one who seek leadership is not worthy of
leadership which is exactly what's
happening every elected politician they
spend the money and also support them to
really convince the people to rather
than the people should convince the
candidate to run for them and represent
them
so this political system is according to
Islam but the implementation is really
run by the people with money have you
had a chance as anyone ever confronted
you and told you go back home
have you dealt with in your experience
someone who's built really hostile but
at the end when you got a chance to sit
with them good things happen I tell you
when I first came to the state they came
in 16 iron yeah and I lived in Wichita
Kansas yes because I went to school
there because Wichita Kansas is known
and is still known as the air capital of
the world I'm an aerospace engineer so I
known a person you're also a semi Imam
right yes yes you're a spiritual leader
yes and I got to know somebody from
Tennessee who lived in so his father was
there and he had couple drinks so he
look at me and said are you Jewish I
said no sir I said what the hell are you
from I said I'm from Egypt he said same
damn thing so this is how the feeling
was at that time however many places has
gone better and many places has gone
worse why because let's face it Muslim
community in America is different than
any other minority community ever lived
in America most of us are highly
educated and doing services to America
at large you won't you won't find a
hospital America that doesn't have a
Muslim doctor you wouldn't have um any
institution or corporation in America
that doesn't have a good Muslim who's
doing good service for America so we are
doing good service for America and this
gives us one-on-one basis to meet
non-muslims in America and they can seed
for themselves even with the tremendous
Islamic phobia that's being bombarding
Muslims and non-muslims to hate Muslims
as a matter of fact people do not
realize that President Nixon in his
memoir after the communist system fell
down
he said we have to create another enemy
and that enemy would be Islam
this is Nixon Nixon yeah so what are you
doing is they telling the American
public look at that look at the monitor
while they are rubbing them blind well
and they have a Nixon said we have to
create a new enemy and this is Islam so
the while you have the enemy you're
distracted and they're robbing you blind
yes this is exactly what's happening
yeah that's exactly what's happening now
the oil price is down to almost 40 bucks
a barrel why is the gas at the gas pump
is still the same price who is making
the difference why you and I am not
making the difference why don't you and
I benefit from that we're spending
billions if not trillions of dollars on
Wars why can't we use this money on the
homeless better education better health
care better America why because they
also have the money they don't benefit
from having good roads or good schools
but they benefit from selling war
machinery and they have the audacity to
make young people believe he's fighting
for his country they are not fighting
for their country they are fighting for
those who owns the ammunition and the
tanks and the aeroplanes and why are we
fighting over there
we have no nothing to do with them the
United States
till today everybody wants to come to
live in the United States so how could
everybody wants to come and live in the
Nastase and hate the United States
doesn't war doesn't make any sense yeah
and why because the United States is
based on the best just system in the
world which is Islam and that's why
people want to come here but how come
they don't want people overseas to live
in peace
quality why they always supporting
dictators why President Trump is going
to India and holding hand with the
Indian Hitler that he's been killing and
burning Muslims and destroying massage
and what can I mess it is he giving to
anybody
why Biden is saying that he doesn't have
to be a Jew to be Zionist and he said I
am Zionist to the core he made a
statement saying the best investment
we're making is the money we'll give it
to Israel and if there was no Israel
would have created Israel why America
has to do with there it's thousands and
thousands of miles there why would an
America help the poor and the needy as
they always did before as the
forefathers did and to be a to be honest
with you I feel that we should have an
American spring take America back and
bring it back to the forefathers time
with no slavery mm-hmm
so you mentioned something where that
you have all of these different roads of
good that could be accomplished and
money can be spent taxpayer money can be
spent to eradicating homelessness
poverty healthcare education but the
majority of the money goes towards war
war killing innocent people on another
part of the planet and that's what
Bernie Sanders is saying and that's why
even the Democratic Party is hating him
mm-hmm
they want somebody else but but if you
don't go over there then they're gonna
come over here and they're gonna take
our way of life and they're gonna take
our freedoms and you're here this is
what's usually said like we have to go
over there so they don't come over here
because they hate us how but you just
say how many of the people I mean people
do not realize that every white person
in America is an immigrant they are all
immigrants the only Americans are the
Native Americans and who among every
terror act has been happening in the
last couple hundred years is happening
by a white man and most of them are
happening against Muslims and minorities
black men did not lynch white men black
men did not burn alive
white men it is white men who have been
killing black men and people of the
color people who have come to live in
the United States in the last couple
hundred years they just came to make a
good living and to get away from the
disaster and the help that then estates
caused them in their own countries I
didn't realize that the CIA was running
the Middle East until I came to the
United States I left Egypt because of
the dictatorship I used to be a first
lieutenant engineer and the Egyptian Air
Force from 65 1965 to the end of 1968 I
went through the six-day war and I saw
the corruption of what's going on in
Egypt from the military and who put the
military in place is the United States
CIA just everybody's read about Kermit
Roosevelt what he did in Iran what he
did in Egypt he was running the Middle
East till today
Trump is saying my favorite dictator
about the Egyptian president who this
honestly ran a coup run by the admission
and the knowledge and the blessings of
the United States and now people say why
are the hating us there isn't any
dictatorship around the world that the
rest is has not supported while and
that's why people want to come here
because at least their estates still
have some freedom for the American
citizens and American inhabitants more
than anyone can have in his own or our
own country
and that's why I am here and many other
ethnicity or here yeah so those some of
those original that are they talked
about in this book what was it like
around 30% the the Muslims from Africa
they were actually brought here by force
they were on the transatlantic ships
trade ships they were kidnapped you know
they were kidnapped from their homes
tortured and brought here and they were
some of the oh yeah the original ones
who came forcefully forcefully here yeah
and he talked about this in the in the
book and do any of these it's it is in
the memoir of Ali yeah the slave and it
is the may be on I'll send you the link
yeah
so you mentioned get send you so now you
had Muslims here in America's in in
America who were befriending the Native
Americans oh yeah and you have evidence
that many of the Native Americans they
also turn to the worship of one only one
God and you have seen a lot of the
writings the pure monotheism yes right
so you had Muslims in America at that
time
and then also forcibly brought here at
that time in history so we've been
Muslims have been here those again
Muslim is one who submits his or her
will to the Creator to have his own
earth the one God so Muslims been here
for since the beginning yes yeah way
before Columbus was even born
uh-huh way before even lumbers this book
actually talks about yes that was just
the introduction of this book ridicule
Columbus and as a fake person yeah that
he has nothing to do with the discovery
of America I mean was this already
discovered at that time and tells you
about the influence of the African
culture that impacted the United States
just just the introduction of the book
of those both books will give you
tremendous knowledge about what has been
happening in the other states
thank you so much for sharing all that
with us we're we're out of time so
people can look up some of this
information you have Thomas Jefferson's
Quran
it's a shame that you they're still
teaching in schools Columbus discovering
America it doesn't take a lot of
research going down investigating to see
that that's it's not true
that's true and those books you can buy
them for less than $20 a book yeah
but the main thing is in bringing up
these points is Muslims are here they've
been here Muslims are those who just
like Jesus Abraham Moses and all the
other prophets they want to live a guy
conscious life they want to submit to
their creator or not the creation they
want to stay away from all immorality
they want to be good upright human
beings they want to work to make America
a better place and we're your neighbors
we're not going anywhere so get to know
Muslim visitors Muslim at the mosque
connection and all we do and all we can
say please come and visit our massage it
as a matter of fact the FBI after 15
years of snooping on Muslim communities
around the nest states they came up with
saying the Muslim community is one of
the best communities in the red states
this is a the FBI after 9/11 for 15
years they have surveillance they have
surveillance of not only the massage
with phone calls internet you name it
and that was the result of all the
surveillance for 15 years is the Muslim
community is one of the best communities
in the United States all we want you
just come and visit us go to our massage
it when you see somebody looks like a
Muslim stop them when you see a woman
covering her here they stop her and ask
her why she's doing this and why she's
doing that knock on our doors and come
and eat with us
mm-hmm visit with us make the human
connection yes you will like it yeah
hates bad for the health bad for the
heart yes and that's not gonna really
guess anywhere thank you so much thank
you very much thank you for being with
us and thank you guys for tuning in
again here to the D show subscribe if
you haven't already you can go ahead and
visit us every week we're trying to
clear the misconceptions bridge those
gaps of misunderstanding and invite you
to come visit us call us also if you
have any questions one
166 to Islam we'll see you next time God
willing in sha Allah we started with
peace we ran with peace peace be with
you assalamu alaikum which by the way it
was a greeting of Jesus and all the
prophets and that same way of life that
they live we're living today and that's
the worship of one and only one God
worship the Creator not the creation so
much to learn but if you can dig that
you can dig the rest and we'll see you
next time peace be with you as Salam
alaykoum but I'm saying even meet not
too much eating meat no good once a week
may be maximum and then vegetable who
moves all good Arabic food Middle East
like in the old time like in the Muslim
look at the Muslim bread almond Apple go
read read you discover in a Muslim a
lots of good thing a very smart Prophet
Mohammed he knew what's good for the
future about the body so look at that
don't ask me and believe me you have
everything